tesla spacex elon musk
currently invest in bitcoin but are
openly looking to explore other
cryptocurrency investments
what case would you make for cardano
well if they truly care about
alternative energy and
sustainability you know carbon reduction
or carbon neutrality
you you can't be in a system where there
is no
built-in mechanism to constrain the
energy consumption
you know with proof of stake energy
consumption is a negative
it's it you want to minimize it if you
can get the same amount of stuff done on
a raspberry pi as you can a big server
you're going to do it on the pi
because ultimately that server cost and
energy cost is coming out of your budget
with proof of work any innovation you
come up with to
optimize power uh you just build more
asics
because you know it's always 30 more
power efficient great buy 30
more you keep you keep you keep you keep
adding to the work set because you want
more hash power more hash power
more share of the pie so you have no
energy savings component and i know
these people are saying well there's a
lot of wasted energy in the grid
and this is kind of incentivizing using
that wasted energy and it's a better way
of storing it than batteries because
you're now storing it as a bitcoin
instead of storing it as energy
okay maybe there's some truth to that
but um
anyway it's just the energy is a
critical uh point for you
like that yeah yeah and that's exactly
right the energy is a critical point
for me with with with tesla because they
assert to be an alternative energy
company
and unless they can make the case that
somehow the proliferation of bitcoin is
legitimately going to proliferate
batteries solar and wind or
other things then it's probably good for
them to just focus
on the most efficient energy efficient
cryptocurrency possible
otherwise you're exacerbating global
warming you're exacerbating the
ecological consequences of it
the other thing is bitcoin is the least
programmable of all the cryptocurrencies
that if you want to do interesting sexy
unique things let's say tesla for
example uh they want to start doing vdi
and vita v
for uh for autonomous vehicles and have
the vehicle start talking to each other
and connect it to 5g
well imagine if you want to build a
telco coin or you know some sort of 5g
coin and you want to build an iot layer
and network
there's just no real way to do that on
bitcoin with the way it's designed
so you'd need fundamentally different
infrastructure to create such a token
and regulate such a system and have
these things autonomously negotiate and
do business with each other you need
dexes and stable coins and all kinds of
mechanics
to make something like that possible
well that's really beneficial to tesla
if they could figure that out
because they could create like an
information sharing incentive scheme
where if the cars talk to each other
including
other branded cars like gm cars and
fords they can now actually get data
from those cars through a marketplace in
exchange
for the benefit of autonomous driving or
for the benefit of understanding road
conditions or safety enhancement and so
forth
so it's just depending are you just here
to speculate are you here to actually
use it as another medium of exchange or
do you actually want to build
infrastructure on this thing
the more closely you get to utility the
further down the road you get there
then the more programmability you need
and so it makes a lot more sense to be
an ethereum fan or a cardano fan than to
be a bitcoin fan so to be both proof of
stake and have the smart contracts
capabilities yes
and that's why we went over ethereum
because they're proof of work
you